yeah okay we carry feet sipping empathy
I know patience is the key put enough on
my ship for free this is tea we carry
feet
Michael make up good morning tea fans it
was me Jerry being early morning 9 a.m.
Eastern Time on this may 15th halfway
through this month we're just kind of
all going through this I hope
everybody's super well I missed you guys
leave a comment if you missed tea with
Gary B yesterday let me know cuz it's
nice to be missed
cuz I missed you guys heavy good morning
good morning good morning hello hello
let's give some shoutouts Tatyana
Spencer good to see you here
Casey Smith Thank You Julio Garcia great
to see you max Hendricks good morning
big shout-out to everybody who just came
over from text on community if you're
not following me on text to one two nine
three one five seven three one two one
two nine three one five seven three one
text me locked me in when the contact
card comes out fill at the info get with
me on it a lot of fun there if you just
came over from text cuz I just blasted
all of you said come and join me for
some tea leave a comment saying text
just reply text or whatever platform
you're using YouTube Facebook Twitter
twitch it's good to have all of you here
so you know there we go see some people
love it yes why text we will get to that
right hook at some point do today all
right let's uh let's uh let's get into
it
Dustin how are you Gus before we get
into it good looking good yeah I took a
shower last night and went straight to
bed and this is what happens I
appreciate that I just I just ran up a
huge hill eight times cardio for life
Jesus oh no I can't do that in the
morning wait this is the camera set up
that me and the rock were telling you
about so I don't know if you can tell
any difference on your end yeah it looks
good cool so yeah well maybe my camera's
better no this camera mic mic every - oh
yeah probably this is the camera you're
gonna send to me
yeah I can't really tell the difference
okay
well maybe I hope your mind is better
that's lighting too it's all that [ __ ]
yeah right let's get into it Gary
what's up man
Abel it is so good to see you bro it see
you too man
Wow literally I've moved in seventh
grade and then I saw you at the
Hillsborough fire station baseball card
comic show yeah sophomore or junior of
high school SATs 92 or 93 and that's it
yeah that's it yeah all right cuz you
that's right you told literally that
triggered you also moved right yeah I
moved to Florida my family at the end of
seventh grade - yeah right at the end of
seventh grade going so we booked so we
both bounced John Adams middle school my
dad and John Adams right at the same
time and then you came back and
graduated JP Stevens no no no I just
came back to see family and then went to
see you so yeah that was cool man you
sold me my first baseball card a Gary
Carter
way back in the day you know it's funny
every time I stumble on anybody that I
grew up with literally the first thing
they say is you saw yeah yeah well true
man it's true I hustled those hard back
then yeah you did man you did you
hustled everything hard everything hard
man you know you don't read about you
that stuff's true that's I remember when
you were a kid taking flowers and
styling them to the people now let me
ask you a question did you sell them to
the same garden they're the same people
this garden you took an animal was it
like neighbors neighbors but sometimes I
think it still man that's that's crazy
that's crazy yeah it's so good to see
you bro good to see you too man good to
see you too I honestly I already really
have a question yeah I just want to see
- yeah what my favorite part of this of
us connecting is how Wrestlemania six or
five five
we watched WrestleMania when macho man
lost - Hogan yeah
that was at your house and I was
devastated that was right around the
time that I knew that it was scripted so
I knew what was gonna play out and I was
still devastated oh I know yeah bet that
was back when wrestling was
you know it was uh yeah it was awesome
and I remember that was the first time
my mom met you when you came over to my
house and literally for like two minutes
she talked to you she went out to find
me and she's like why can't you be more
like your friend Gary the guy he could
be a horrible guy and she's like well is
he no that's not the damn point you know
what I mean but it was funny man was
good times I think some of the best
friends you have are the ones when
you're kids because it's before all the
[ __ ] you know what I mean
you know it's crazy when I think back we
really really got close in at John Adams
like that's when our friendship got much
stronger in six and seventh grade like
yeah were you there when I fought Oded
Weinstock and Marcos Hill Oded Weinstock
yes I was you was asked that was a big
one that was a big one for me that's by
highlighting middle school
oh that was funny hey man do you
remember a regime corty remember that
where Sean was my guy yeah in fourth
grade he was like the only other kid
that I was that like was good at like
great at dodgeball Sean Sean was my guy
guy I know that was awesome but I
remember like me and resigned or was on
we were kind of close but not really but
before we were close it was after school
one day and you wanted to fight yeah and
you know you and him and Danny Vega
those were like the toughest kids in
school I remember it was after school
and you know the big circle formed and
I'm looking honestly I'm looking for you
on my help you know but of course not
this was Jersey in the 80s
nobody [ __ ] back down there
recyclable never remember the Williams
twins who were younger but tougher than
[ __ ] everyone yeah those are the big
kids right yes Robbie and I'm trying to
many other kids not the other one either
now this is funny because I remember the
big circle formed and then here you come
out of nowhere you know I'm ready to
fight I'm ready to get my ass whooped
because I'm gonna fight but I don't want
to fight you know so here you cuz I was
tough yeah and I remember you said
what's going on here Andruw Jones like
imma whoop his ass and you said why and
he said cuz I don't like him and
literally I remember this happening you
look right at him and you went why and
he looked at you like a cow fence yeah
and he was like all right so he didn't
what my ass so I never got to thank you
for that but I
man that was awesome do you remember you
remember playing our version like soccer
and hockey on the sidewalk with the with
the [ __ ] Rock yeah what would the
rock with a smash coke and like we stood
you ready for this this is a true story
I was so addicted to that soccer hockey
game with the rock and the can after
that I would get home so late then
because I used to walk home that my mom
would get nervous cuz I would get home
so late so finally one is a true story
one time my mom goes you have to be home
after school today like do not [ __ ]
around no [ __ ] hockey said my mom
she's shaking her head in the background
she goes I go okay mom I promise
sure enough [ __ ] after school like
I'm trying to leave but the game is so
good I have to jump in everything's
gonna be just one minute but 30 minutes
later game ends now I'm petrified cuz my
mom is rut [ __ ] old school Russian
she's gonna whip my ass is not some
American like never like her so I start
running and when I tell you running
running home like full-speed there's a
short so it's on a street and there's a
shortcut you remember Eric Godfrey he
was a year older than us do you know
that name
you might not know him but he was in my
neighborhood his I could cut so he could
you could run home and go to the street
but there was a shortcut that would get
me faster so I'm running home and I'm
watching every car that's driving to
John Adams hoping my mom's car's not
there cuz I knew she would come sure
enough just as I'm running down the hill
and I look back to see the final cars
that I could see before I can't see any
more cars I see my mom's Mercury Topaz
[ __ ] driving and my [ __ ] like it
was over like I do it I will never
forget that we literally love that game
so it was literally soccer slash hockey
on pavement with a rock or a crushed
soda can
yeah yeah able I remember that super
well I know that was awesome man that
was awesome so I got a new baby
congratulations Thank You Man she's
gonna have to wheel me to her graduation
but now man you'll be the best 61 year
old
it's so good to see you brother I love
you it's been so good to reconnect talk
to you soon good stuff it's fun to have
those you know what's fun is like some
of those stories and fun because you
forget some of the stuff that was shot
Courtney's story I completely remember
now and it was like something that's
1984 [ __ ] I always believed in kindness
even back then so anyway let's keep it
go hi Sarah hey Gary how are things
these are really good on the west coast
it's early thanks for getting up early
uh yeah whatever it takes of course um
so four years in the making since I
tweeted you and you tweeted back so for
everybody's watching right out yesterday
I think you tweeted right yeah I just
responded to the tweet which was like
four years ago Sarah said something I
said well we should talk that and had
literally yesterday she retweeted it and
wrote over it's like can we book this
and I saw it I'm like yep let's book it
and here we are what's so funny Gary is
then your team that says just get ready
with a question and I thought this is
what's so funny is that I obviously
known about that tweet for 14 years
and I thought about messaging you in the
past it was because I wanted something
and I then I would do this thing where
big what's he gonna tell me he's gonna
tell me strength you to chew he's gonna
tell me they did it so just beautiful
and then yesterday we were supposed to
have our ten-year celebration at the
organization that way and I was sitting
with my house not feeling sorry for
myself like just like thinking like do
you know supposed to be at that party
and I'm here and like look what we've
done during the pandemic for our kids
and and I was like you know as we
haven't been a victim during this time
you've been so resourceful we've been
like just just doing such a great job
and like just on it and I thought it's
got time thank you so that's why I did
it so then when they messaged me they're
like uh there a question I was like
there's like I mean I thought of them
obviously I've had time to think of it
but I was like wait that's not even what
I did in this you know what's so
powerful about that like the other times
you've thought about it it was from a
place of need yes yesterday was
from a place of giving and literally the
universe decided to serendipitously
allow me to see it and and then it
creates the moment and I and I really
mean this like that [ __ ] [ __ ] freaks
me out like when I hear that story like
it really makes me believe like like it
just there's just something so obvious
no different I'm sure you're just
watching with Abel right like like Abel
still feels the impact of a third grade
fight that I stopped out of kindness
like like good brings on more good and
bad brings on more bad and I believe in
that [ __ ] and I and I feel a huge sense
of responsibility as a good communicator
that people are associated with and
attracted to and drawn to to put out as
much good as possible when I hear that
story from you just now it [ __ ]
reinforces what I believe
I mean it's eight minutes later and then
the funny thing was the tweets rolling
in like oh she's been like loading that
like she's like it's not me it happens
all the time and there's people I feel
horrible because sometimes I see it but
I'm not in that mindset like you know at
at number four 94 to get Gary Venus
follow me or say hi like you know it's
it's hard I'm out here operating and
navigating and trying my best and you
know you know 5,000 texts today 10,000
DMS a day thousands of tweets like it's
it's you'll never beat the math but my
intent is there and and like you you
make lemonade out of these lemons like
this this whole pandemic has let me
connect with the community at a level T
with Gary Vee is a connection point that
is greater than askgaryvee is greater
than is greater than anything I've done
I think really honestly it's it's got a
different level of depth and calmness
and and and speed that I think is really
connected and helped both me and
everybody who's watching it
well it's I'm grateful and I was
thinking last night about how I started
this nonprofit in 2008 I had been laid
off and when this whole thing hit 75
days ago yeah I remember when we when I
was in New York and I flew back to
California
uh I just and you're talking about this
in one of your shows recently it's like
I didn't get
service it's like I've done I mm like I
built this in jail I'm like no I know
noise and my brother an entrepreneur in
his own right in real estate he
introduced me to you 10 years ago and
sometimes we'll be hanging out I'll be
like he's like W mix up the big the big
thing for everybody who likes to
complain and dwell and be a victim they
need to realize that nobody cares
because they're worried about their own
problems and the only people that are
caring and and coddling you are the
people that extremely love you and
enable it or other people that are
[ __ ] losing like complaining and
dwelling is a bad formula because it
creates two bad relationships it creates
a relationship with another losing
player and you're just negative on
negative and you're just literally
hanging out in your [ __ ] sorrow
bubble or it's putting somebody that
loves you so much
in a peculiar spot where they're
enabling you which eventually leads to
resentment by both parties uh yeah
complaining and dwelling is bad it
really hurts relationships and people
that love you don't want you to sit in
that and it's interesting because I
don't know if you know what I do but I
mean I help teens become entrepreneurs
we start the teens tweening
and he'll be happy to know that our
teens run our social media because there
is no excuse for not having it but I
personally do not I feel like tick tock
is like my jam
pretty much so your jam well I mean I'm
saying like the kids they totally know
it hey you're good but in four hours it
could be your jam yes and you'll teach
me the fun thing is to be in situations
where I can go to our to our kids our
teens are tweens but let me let me take
this moment up Sara let me take this
moment because I'm gonna help a lot of
people let me tell you how to get taught
on tik-tok snapchat LinkedIn or the next
three things that happen in the next
decade you go immediately and you
consume content on the platform for 10
hours okay and then you make 10 pieces
of content 10 hours 10 pieces of content
is how you learn every platform go in
download it read read write don't judge
them don't say it's stupid 10
hours of consuming ten pieces of content
giving you your best and then reassess
ten hours ten pieces of content is how
every single person can learn a new
social network well you should check it
out because they were shouting you out
yesterday I will check it out it is such
a pleasure I'm glad we did this
yeah thanks for and everybody um I want
to thank you Gary you gave a tip in a
video recently about just reaching out
to people in the DMS on Instagram and
we're doing a virtual entrepreneurship
summer camp and I've reached out to
celebrity entrepreneurs in every space
and we've had some great yeses that
would probably not be chilling at their
house right now
can't get a yes if you don't ask yeah so
thank you Gary take care bye bye
just what are the updated numbers I want
to start creating the competition I want
to get Twitter YouTube Facebook and
twitch to start sharing their URLs to
their community to get to the highest
number we have to do like a pizza party
for the best part of it cool so oh yeah
YouTube is 3,000 Facebook is 2800 yep
it's close twitch looks like it's 330
yep and Twitter looks about 300 30 or 20
ish also okay let's keep it going
Katy Wow how are you I'm very well but
you're beautiful setting is inspiring
it's the best place to be good for you
it's really nice to see you you too
I'm so excited I'm playing what would
Gary say all week so all of my questions
I have filtered through what your
response would be and I've made a bunch
of changes this week but Grant did you
feel any impact of any of those changes
yet I mean it's early you have yeah give
me give me one example so we have a farm
market and we do home delivery
throughout the Capital Region upstate in
New York um and obviously all food
delivery has skyrocketed in the last few
weeks yes and you know it's just growing
so exponentially that you know we just
took no it was scattered so yes of
course when when chaos
it's happening at wine text right now
Katie like we hired nine the Springfield
New Jersey pool shut down for the summer
so we hired all nine lifeguards like and
like inevitably some of those kids are
gonna ship the wrong bottle of wine it
you know like it's just it's just you
know you when it gets to chaos the KKT
is to not beat yourself up if somebody
gets corn instead of apples you could
always fix anything by saying you're
sorry and addressing it yeah and I think
too many people worry about perfection
or like if we deliver the wrong thing it
gets put on Facebook and everybody gets
spent it's I'm sorry and meaning it is
the greatest anecdote to anxiety around
making a mistake in business and in life
yeah and I try to be super transparent
I'm like listen we went from just me I
had knee surgery on February 11th and
then three days later I was delivering
things I couldn't put shoe on yet so
that was cool we're gonna get food out
I'm impressed and that you know then we
just where I'm like 30 X what I was
January February yeah have you hired yes
that's my challenge um people don't like
to show up to work I know a lot of times
we we hired four people last week and
only one showed up and we like and
Brandon who my best friend who has great
EQ higher as well and like really like
communicated well like I think what it
comes down to is not dwelling on that
recognizing that's gonna be part of the
game learning and hiring a couple more
people than you need just in case they
don't show up in first day or quit after
day one both happen no show and quit
after day one but the reality is you
just keep pushing at Facebook Craigslist
LinkedIn or all good places to get you
know individuals I think emailing you're
in all your customers and saying we're
hiring some of those people want to get
their teenage kids out of the house so
the I think there's some packs there
yeah and I've done a little bit of
outsourcing to do so that I don't have
to do everything in the house good job
and I simplified things because I was
like you know
it ends up I'm pretty much the primary
delivery person and we're doing like a
big range and I love driving that's fine
that's no big deal um but I love you
know the marketing in like that's that's
my gym that's where I am you know
content and marketing and business
development and customer relations and
you know would you handwritten thank-you
cards and the orders like that's that's
my thing that's what part of New York
are you I want to make sure anybody
who's got friends and relatives in the
area we are in Saratoga Springs yes and
what sure yeah what do you deliver
through what it was County County
Schenectady County Rensselaer County
Washington County I love a big shout out
to my homie homie Joe Minich our Tokyo
Joe as we called them in college from
Schenectady New York
I miss your nachos you're watching love
it so do i you have a specific question
maybe I can help with what is the best
way to skip I don't you just go huge
I just need skip you know I'm at like 15
20 degrees I can with our current
infrastructure I compile you hit like 50
and I don't know so you don't have
demand for 50 yet I do I just can't I
don't infrastructure meaning the amount
of food you make you just it's the
delivery part so you mean the delivery
infrastructure is not up to the level of
being able to do 50 mostly the people
and the supply chain and that stuff is
it a height is it a hiring I think so
yeah I think so too I think I think you
can't be disappointed when you hire two
people and spend two weeks on it and
they don't show up and so right now
during this time especially you need to
hire anybody who's willing to say yes
and you need to take risks yeah you know
Ricki might drive away with the food and
eat in this house that might happen and
then he'll call Susan or they put on the
wrong porch like you're gonna happen I
think it's okay to go there I think
because here's what people to understand
but they don't eat it but they don't put
on the wrong porch 90% of time it's okay
and people think the 10% is the hundred
percent they fear yeah and I don't I'd
rather say I'm sorry and and I believe
in people and I believe in the good and
I believe it's gonna be okay and I'm
optimistic optimism is practical it
helps grow
and so you just can't be scared start
with friends and family you know start I
would literally go into your phone from
A to Z tonight coffee tea wine however
you roll a to Z from 6:00 p.m. to
midnight and text every person and say
hey do you know anybody who wants to
work because I need four to five like I
mean all of them
you know that's already started and then
no no all of us cool how that happens
but I don't think you know you hit up
your closest friends you didn't hit up
somebody that you met six years ago and
have their phone in your number in your
address book yeah that's what I would do
okay all right good luck
it's just hi so much don't fear don't
fear the no show Katie don't fear the
wrong delivery and I guarantee it will
work out awesome
I mean I'm positive you're welcome I
appreciate it people people really fear
hiring I've seen this happen so much
like like weave meets I've made an
ungodly amount of bad hires because I
don't fear it you can always fire that
person you can always say sorry you can
always lose one customer but but if you
don't hire them you're stuck at fifteen
they're not fifty simple let's keep
moving it garyvee it what's going on man
that's good Andrew how you doing this is
awesome thank you so much for the
opportunity really appreciate it so I
gotta give you a little bit of a back
story just so you can kind of get
contact on everything so five years ago
I started a social media marketing
agency was super tough at first made it
happen
sold it within two years and then
transfer over to e-commerce throughout
this whole time I've always wanted to
really do mentorship type stuff speak
because of you actually I was always
afraid of like creating content putting
myself out there for whatever is it I
don't know why but I listen to you
finally a month ago and honestly I think
I found my calling like this is awesome
I loved every second of it and I don't
it's really cool within Andrew knowing
that you did a social media shop and
e-commerce and want to be a contra
Nouriel personal brand
the only vulnerability the guy like you
has in the cliche scenario is don't fake
the funk oh you already
but I knew you were I knew where you
were going based on your setup yeah it's
just you're you will win if you don't
[ __ ] and too many guys like you
[ __ ] because they can't wait to get
to the [ __ ] stage part and the
verified part and the fame part and
that's awesome there's nothing wrong
with that but make sure you you really
talk about the truth of how good or not
good your social media agency was how
good or not good you are at ecommerce
you see it every day people can't wait
to get to know the kind of fame part and
so they they kind of embellish or over
exaggerate how good an entrepreneur they
were and it [ __ ] always always always
bites them in the ass in the end that
makes sense well let me let me ask you
so my main concern and you're definitely
you're on the right track 100% obviously
but my main concern is when I was
younger from 18 to like 23 24 I had a
heroin addiction so I think it's growing
every day I've been sober yeah I've been
sober ever since and it's powerful the
response I'm getting is cool but I
haven't gone public with it and I don't
know well you just did yeah I know I
said it my question like by this might
as well do it I'm so proud of you bro
thank you you know hard that is to
achieve that double I well that's that's
part of the whole thing I remember in
the thick of it I would be like I
remember specific time where I was
sitting on my couch when it was all
happening I thought I was never gonna
get out of if I was gonna be like 75
years old and I was just gonna be an
addict you know or be in that space and
I feel like I could help a lot of people
you can but I'm also afraid that it'll
hurt my credibility no it will it'll
double up your credibility really yeah
it will double up your credibility yeah
yeah I just I just felt like there's a
negative connotation look it's a it's a
it's not it for whoever it's a negative
comment you know whoever thinks it's a
negative some is somebody you don't want
in your community it's somebody who
doesn't understand it's a disease and
it's casting
without [ __ ] any knowledge of how the
actual game is played there you know
what I mean brother yeah that's all like
like like like honestly as a matter of
fact for example in that story in your
truth is exactly the reason why somebody
would be more connected to you than
connected to me because they're going
through an alcohol addiction or opiate
addiction you know what I mean and I
can't give them that but you can yeah
you know like like like you know that's
why so many people aren't getting any
traction there just talking vanilla yeah
they're watching my [ __ ] and
regurgitating it Congress right now a
hundred percent a hundred percent
absolutely it's your biggest strength
bro it's it's the biggest it's the
biggest thing you got not to mention I
believe and this is coming out of pure
love out of my heart for you
specifically I also think that it's if
you make it a pillar you stand on that
it gives you a better chance to fight it
off for the rest of your life because
what people don't know and what you do
know is this a forever is a forever game
and a lot of people win that forever
game it seems daunting in their 20s yeah
I've met a lot of people who have had
real addiction issues in their 40s and
the thing they keep telling me is that
in your 20s after your 30s after you've
gotten through it you know and you've
been in it and you're in year 1 or 2 and
3 then it starts and you're happy but
then you're psychic I got to fight this
for 60 more years and it sometimes feels
daunting really and kind of getting out
of the shadows and letting everybody
know about it has actually given them
energy to then go about 20 years instead
of relapsing two years later yeah
yeah that makes sense that makes perfect
sense
that's all c'mon brother it is your
strength
yeah like like like if like nope ready
for this bro in 2009 people literally
told me and and people told me to my
face and told my agents that they would
not book me to speak because I cursed
mm-hmm but I just stuck to my truth well
they're you know do I think that you
know dare but you know do I think like
the most conservative that I actually
dare what but like do I think the most
conservative
company won't hire you because of that
sure if they've demonized drugs and sort
of you know but do I think three other
companies will yes yeah like don't don't
worry about it as a stigma when it's
your strength
most people think their stigma most
people have feel a stigma I was raped I
had an opium addiction I went to jail I
you know you know fast cyber like you
know security breaches that put me in
like probation like most people think
that their stigma especially when it's
not you know as long as you don't murder
someone rape someone as long as it
doesn't to the top five to seven things
in culture you can't come back from all
right that's right our society is wildly
forgiving and it's actually our strength
but most people think it's their demon
and it's not it's their strength yeah
that makes sense and it makes perfect
sense some kid that we hired said to me
Gary I just feel like I should say this
to you and work for little ways like I
went to jail but you guys don't know
about it it was like so yeah and then I
was like for what and they told me was
not that bad wasn't good okay yeah you
know like no that makes perfect sense
it's just lean into it and I honestly I
thought of that to it I just didn't know
if it would if it would the positives
would outweigh the negatives and I
remember there were times where I feel
like still to this day if I watched a
video of somebody like me now back then
I probably would have gotten sober a
couple years earlier or would have
helped me in one way or another you know
I just yep yep
bro shadows are heavy yeah shadows
secrets slow you down but do you
understand that
forget about of course the positives are
gonna outweigh the negatives you're not
gonna have to think yeah what are you
gonna do when you're on what were you
doing when you were thinking about this
and laying there and saying okay one day
I'm gonna be like Gary Vee and I'm gonna
be on stage I'm doing QA and so I was
like yo dude didn't you go the heroin
they feel like I [ __ ]
my brother knows you like what we're
going to do what we gonna do in that
moment you can't have that moment no
absolutely yeah you were you would have
sabotage your own upside because we had
a feared the exposing moment people need
to put out their stigmas to the world
because their secret is sabotaging their
upside because they have to overthink
every move because they haven't exposed
their stigma absolutely it's good that I
do it now before it ever gets that any
point like that and even then you should
be like and [ __ ] you yeah bro
everybody's got [ __ ] yeah and you're a
hero to break through it not the other
way around
sure it's a disease bro you're not bad
this is in 1984 anymore
yeah Nancy Reagan out isn't out here
shaming us come on let's get our [ __ ]
together man this is a disease I'm proud
of you
you [ __ ] accomplished more in
breaking that habit than 90 [ __ ]
percent of people are doing their life I
need that to be really under there I
really appreciated that that's super
awesome man I really do thank you so
much thank you for the opportunity man
stuff I really this is awesome honestly
thank you you're welcome
talk to you soon let's keep it moving
hey hey what's up good morning I'm super
excited here I think and I like super
whoa whoa yeah wait is that they they
both look great Kendall don't worry all
right I got a light and everything I'm
like so I'm really professional right
now I don't I look like [ __ ] like
everyone's I get a light I'm like I
don't give a [ __ ] so much they've been
trying to give you on this week but you
know what's crazy is like this whole
week I have been waking up thinking I'm
gonna be on like I get up at like 5:00
a.m. in California and it's really
changed because then Tuesday Thursday
did the same thing and I was like dude
I'm [ __ ] down for this I'm ready so I
I'm kind of okay
so you got it so you're in Cali you look
obviously I only get to so many they
have to prep for who how many I get to
so you started Monday like you thought
you might be on today if we got to so
Monday and so you got to get up super
early and then because you did it all
week you were waking up what time before
like 9 a.m. 8 a.m. just like that kind
of yeah I was that's and now you're on
this so are you going to sleep a little
bit earlier yeah I'm going to sleep a
little bit earlier I'm cute and you like
this by better I love it I love it I am
a professional athlete so I've been
waking up super early my entire life but
now with like coronavirus how things are
like kind of changed I was just telling
my mom earlier like the difference
between wake going to sleep at 2:00 and
waking up at like 9:00 or 10:00 and
doing the opposite where I wake up at
6:00 and you know whatever like the
hours are the same but what I get done
from 10:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m. is so
different from 6:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m.
so it's been [ __ ] awesome so thank
you guys just for that you know it's
funny you know what's funny is I've
always had one of the biggest reasons I
always knew I could never live in LA is
because the world navigates around New
York that's just the truth and like the
thought of waking up at like 8 a.m. but
it's 11 a.m. in New York and the world's
been moving gives me anxiety mm-hmm
you know like like people when I'm on
the west coast on business I wake up at
like 6 cuz and even that's like like
it's kind of funny yeah um anyway so so
super excited to be here and I just took
as my questions do you know what
what jiu-jitsu is Brazilian jiu-jitsu I
do ok ok big shout out to Lou levy from
one of my good buddies who's super about
it good awesome awesome cool so seven
time world champion I'm a trained since
I was a little kid um and my main
question is cuz I like you and everybody
else in the world have a lot of spinning
plates so I'm a professional athlete my
parents owned a bunch of or three digits
of academies and I work at full time and
kind of like you I work with with the
wine or the liquor store I work at them
full-time my salary stays the same but
my goal is to grow the business and
reinvest the the profits and it's been
growing like crazy the last few years
when I got back from one one year of
attended college so it's been great
and also I wrestle I was an
international for Team USA and now and I
was really touched by was it Andrew that
was just on I was super touched by him
because I'm about to hit my four year
anniversary of being recovered from
bulimia which has been a huge
interesting thing in combat sports with
making weight and that's a whole other
topic and then also I'm a super [ __ ]
passion about real estate and I have all
this stuff going on right so I have like
a small following on Instagram like
around eighteen or nineteen thousand
most of it fans of my sport tik-tok I
have like a thousand it's super small
and my question how many times would be
posted on tik-tok so good question I
posted about 20 times and only in the
last week have I really gone up to like
two three times a day and I'm trying to
stay consistent because the only tech
talk I've ever had go viral is of my dog
my dog super buggy cute but you know
what but you know what yeah people
people this is something that people get
confused on I think you milk that what's
dog's name Bella I think you milk Bella
for like a couple months and then you
slide in the jiu-jitsu stuff I mean that
like look I have you know like I really
believe in that like I think people like
oh but Gary says don't post like don't
just do it for the likes on the flip
side you know there's a lot of fun stuff
you can do with Bella and Bella's part
of your life believe is part of your
life who's part of your life Real
Estate's party your life I think you can
mix it all too many people try to make
their content too narrow
okay so so with the content and I'm kind
of like what you're saying I'm doing
like body positivity stuff I'm just kind
of like my boyfriend super nerdy
obsessed with Star Wars so I'm sorry too
like I'm dude I convinced him to start
going on tik-tok and he's like the least
social media person ever I was like
there's a place for you Gary B said
there's a place for you so that's
another thing but and and by the way you
two as a combo is a [ __ ] viral hit
like the nerdy Star Wars dude with the
black belt [ __ ] badass chick like you
got to like not okay
good thing I didn't call nerdy Star Wars
in his face go ahead but okay cool
so you're on the Conn I'm gonna keep
doing nine that's actually I put a video
Pam on my tik-tok for the first time
yesterday of us doing a self-defense
thing so I'm pumped about that um so so
my question is for jiu-jitsu and
wrestling because our sport is hard as
[ __ ] but it does not make a lot of money
there's no NBA there's no MLB there are
some sponsors like like for me like the
[ __ ] are weird like in a few weeks I
have a fight where I'm like 2002 in 2006
Joe hurt she doesn't you know 2002 win
then I have something that I pay to fly
there and like there's no payment then I
have something it's 500 so it's super
all over the place and I was I have some
sponsors but it's not that much it's
like fair that it
I make way more from like working at the
school yep Sony how what is your I
really want to see if there's a way like
I live [ __ ] with Ashley Graham okay
she's she's like amazing I want to see
if there's a way that I can get in so
that will bringing more eyes like it I
can save you time yes the answers yes
your charisma and energy is so strong
you you like having okay you you just
need to go completely apeshit obsessive
which you're capable of you know given
what you've achieved in your life I'm
being a Content machine okay you just
can look you're exactly the kind of girl
that needs to be putting out 25 to 40
pieces of content a day okay meeting
people unique exactly you go to Twitter
and you search every jujitsu terminology
and the term and you reply to everybody
one more time for the kids in the back
who don't know how Gary Vee was created
in 2006 from 2006 to 2011 for five years
I would apply it to every single person
that tweeted at me and I at first when
nobody knew who I was I jumped into
every word that was mentioned on Twitter
about wine and joined the conversation
and I put out a daily wine video every
single day okay kind of you have so much
charisma and like great energy and cute
and interesting and have believe me like
you up everything for you
okay so just more content I like even
the way you talk I [ __ ] with hate like
you've got it okay yeah I do that I got
Instagram going I got Twitter and I got
tick-tock I have like 50 followers on
Twitter so I'm writing everyone that has
to get you in their thing so I sound
good [ __ ] is this
is this your handle across the board it
is it's so Kendall loosing is obvi
obviously my name my last name is
reintroducing but it looks like reusing
I don't I wanted to make everything pet
Marie
so it's fuzzy no Kendall no no this is
back to Andrew like people people think
that like you're seeing it's like oh no
it's reusing Kendall reusing is the
[ __ ] funniest that's exactly right
I'm telling you like like like like I'm
telling you like you know you're not bad
a user handle name's Gary B with two
silent E's are yo you got to check out
Gary B they go in Gary B the wreck where
is this [ __ ] in the beginning it was
like like it's just like it you will
make a name a newly made you understand
he's fine
I would even if I were you I'd be like
and this is Kendall reusing just kidding
Riesling it's a thing I see I see like
like a second hand shop like your
biggest sponsor should be could be
goodwill because people reuse probably
like I'm telling you no it's the same
way as like a scar like like every
everybody thinks their scarlet letter is
their shortcoming it's their strengths
okay okay I I see I see I'm I'm down
with it I'm down so everything you every
people learn to spell it it's not like
what do you mean learn to spell it
everybody knows how to spell reusing
like everybody like I wouldn't know what
what's your last name again I apologize
it's really right I wouldn't know how to
spell Rouge think I'd be like ro osin
like like reuse like know what you think
is your strength
okay okay and last thing how much
content do you consume to stay on trend
but not to get sucked into the black
hole because take top is black hole
sometimes for me when you're consuming
it for strategy unlimited when you're
consuming it for escapism because you're
bored or you're using it for you know
leisure because you're not happy with
what you're doing
aha I could swim zero social media
for entertainment I use this for
entertainment and then that's about it I
use it for strategy and learnings like
the black hole is when you're using it
because you're not fired up about what
you're doing in your life or do you just
need a break I don't want to demonize an
hour I'm just going in the feed do you
but but but like it's very simple it
comes completely down to are you doing
this because you're actually studying
like I'm infeed studying right okay like
I'm not like oh that's funny I'm like
why do you do that what's that hashtag
how many seconds was that when it looked
good to read the comments read the
comics read it why do they love mail you
Sally but you know what yeah okay okay
and then okay last thing I'm gonna get
you to the next person because I'm now
that person that's cutting people off
better in life a little bit Ashley
Graham like just the whole world there's
some other people that I follow as well
how do I like how do I other than cut
like I know I'm creating content how do
I burst into that world coming from an
athlete in a sport that's not mainstream
patience okay one single picture where
you you know when you're looking you're
honest your true self but your copy is
powerful clicks the attention of one
person and you're on the Today Show okay
I see just keep doing that and get in
front of as many eyes it's [ __ ] reps
how do I become a black belt
that's my company class every day
whether you feel like it or not got it
okay I got my lot I love totally I think
we had somebody else during this two
months who was black belt I said how'd
you get yeah right Kendall right how'd
you do it like that's why I'm a black
belt in what I do like you've got to put
in the [ __ ] work okay
it's the work and that's why I work so
much a mindset just like in your world
it's [ __ ] mindset if you're insecure
of how you look or what people gonna say
or that you only have 13 followers but
your buddy has 400 or whatever [ __ ] it
is when you said I have a small audience
and Instagram and throughout Sena 419
that whatever number you threw out
everybody gasped because they have 310
yeah
yeah it's always like comparing is like
I get into this whole stop right there
where I don't want to go [ __ ] no no no
come on Harry
that's [ __ ] if I could [ __ ] take that
word and beat the living [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of it I could think if I could take
comparing and [ __ ] chokehold the [ __ ]
out of it like you know how yeah that
[ __ ] word I [ __ ] hate that one and
I don't people follow me I don't use
hate office yeah I hate that word you
went right to where I wanted you to
right there I [ __ ] hate that word but
but I'm telling you you have to [ __ ]
fight everything's hard yeah and like
that my ability to not compare is a core
foundational strength I I'm not only do
I not compare when I see other business
men and women do things that I haven't
accomplished yet I applaud if they've
done it the right way right I think it's
so [ __ ] awesome to watch people
accomplish things I just wonder it's
because I'm not getting the same
response in my Dustin throw up
Whitaker's my dad's comment I want to
address this cuz it's super fun for me
like it's a super fun comment for me I'm
sorry Kevin I just want a job because
it's one of my favorite subject matters
that's not enough you see it Whitaker's
my dad yellow emoji on Twitch like it's
one of my favorite comments about my
energy that I think a lot about doesn't
you sleep in where you can't find it I'm
sure I'm trying to find it it's in
between very eyes embalmer and and Ramon
eyes en David a Braves near there Judith
Seles it was at 9:45 p.m. Whittaker is
my dad um Kendall you got this like like
compared you know I'm sorry I can appear
like when I'm when I I applaud people
for doing what I haven't done yet and I
think it's [ __ ] awesome and and that's
amazing but I worried that because I'm
not getting the same response on my
content that means I'm not doing what I
needs to take to get to that level if
that makes sense
that's super smart the problem is you
haven't done enough [ __ ] okay it's the
same reason people
are mad that they don't have an orange
belt and they want to give up you're
literally doing the thing you understand
the best okay just do more more and more
oh you don't have context yet okay
you haven't been doing it long enough
okay got it
I got you thank you thank you so much
you're welcome correct
what is your dad what super interesting
is how many people think that who
confuse optimism and happiness and and
you know just genuine gratitude with in
performance enhancement drugs like like
if I took an Advil I go to sleep because
of how little medicine and drugs like my
family like the demonization in the
Eastern European family and especially a
bi mom who was super affected by Nancy
Reagan no drugs no alcohol like it's so
fun to me that is like I'm always
wondering like who writes that comment
what are they are do they do that all
they do they are they solo they must be
so not optimistic that they couldn't
imagine being happy
which drives the energy makes me really
compassionate and empathetic what if you
want to be on the show that does to know
it I really think about this [ __ ] when
people write it because I'm pumped I
don't know anyway let's keep it going
it's so obvious to me that happiness has
the most energy like there is no
artificial drug that beats gratitude it
just doesn't exist
alright let's keep it going how's that
drink bro it's good now it's so good to
see you bro I'm so I'm so proud of you
I've been so enjoying you navigate you
know I've been on you for a minute just
cheering you along from the sidelines
bro you're doing it out here yeah you
are man I'm really proud of you Thank
You Man appreciate it
what's be good oh nothing I just dropped
the project I know I just do it really
well
you know I put all my you know energy my
whole being into this like every day
thinking about it all day thinking about
getting better like I drove myself nuts
just always being like Oh in this video
I'm not getting better I'm not getting
better I'm not getting
told me to just keep getting better I'm
just here now and I'm just like [ __ ]
like the whole last year and like but
like a quarter has been worth it I don't
know it's kind of crazy it's like
running through the finish line in the
marathon probably haven't even started
give too much talent in your body
oh you mean started I don't give a [ __ ]
how great this project goes bro you
haven't even [ __ ] started yeah you're
a [ __ ] youngster you've got stories
and soul I really have it bro yeah you
know back to what I was saying earlier
to Kendall like I watch you know I watch
I puts me onto so much stuff I watch
myself I'd like that you know like I
just know where you're at
yeah sure anything on your mind anything
I can help you with tick-tock what's
your tick-tock strategy for this for
this project cuz bro I'm telling you to
be in music and not have a crazy
tick-tock strategy for everything you do
it's a huge [ __ ] mistake and I'm
feeling your energy and I'm really glad
you came on the show because I need a
much bigger [ __ ] strategy bro my
question for you during this time we
can't do like you know shows and promo
and stuff like that like going to do pop
ups or whatever like what would be your
strategy to promote your app lives
content lives content but I'm telling
you even if the whole world was wide
open the number one piece of advice I
would tell an artist is to win tick tock
tick tock okay
tick tock bro I would DM literally DM
all 100 500 top tick tock stars to be
like yo here's my project tell me if you
[ __ ] with it and if you want to do a
little collab piece of content let's go
and one of those little [ __ ] makes a
dance and it's [ __ ] over
smart smart you know you know what's sad
is they I don't know it's super bad yeah
looks like unacceptable yeah bro it's
not except that you just said to me like
I don't breathe oxygen I'm so you know
why I'm so excited right now because
I've been waiting for my name drop in
one of your [ __ ] songs anyway so now
you now I'm thinking
oh he's gonna say Gary do you put me on
that talk then I went to the blog I'm
already trying to listen to me you need
to go hard on it yo hit hit up the crew
let let's get on a zoom this weekend or
that's gonna zoom Monday because I'm Tay
I'm gonna kind of try to defrag this
weekend but like I will help you I
really really really think you
understand the culture and the
youngsters love you you go in there and
really do it right you're on the verge
bro you're on the verge of some
crazy-ass [ __ ] and you know you know how
much time I spent with gonna and keed
and like the baby like I'm telling you
listen to me yeah you have to go hate
you need to download it I just said it
earlier either download it 10 hours of
consuming it just watch it [ __ ]
what's going on there and then 10 pieces
of content bro you're this close you get
one thing lit off on [ __ ] on
tick-tock right now during this project
and you go to a completely different
level completely different level bro you
have to write remember when you were
coming up and the [ __ ] winners and
old cats didn't understand SoundCloud
didn't understand the Graham that's
you're too young to be old now yeah I'm
gonna hit you up like Sunday night be
like yo what the [ __ ] yeah I need a
dress but I love you less talking boy
that's a superstar that's a superstar
you'll see mom that man right there
might be playing in Xander's Bar Mitzvah
cuz he's gonna beg for it hey Sydney I D
I mean how are you I'm getting real well
um I'm coming at them very on
radio-canada first off I just obviously
want to thank you for having me on the
show and I'd like to commend a little
and Andrew for talking about their
struggles because I know how hard that
can be especially on a platform like
this it can be like really
very daunting well I have a question for
you and then just a bit of context first
so our game 22 years old I am a month
away from graduating at Western
University for kinesiology which is it's
like the movement of the body yeah like
what it undergoes during exercise and
everything so when I was first starting
high school I was really athletic
growing up I actually developed an
eating disorder and it was with me for
seven years
thank you I'm actually two weeks away
from being discharged from my recovery
program congratulations thank you so
much so the issue with this is when I
was in like the peak of my eating
disorder I jumped with the opportunity
to take kinesiology because it was so
focused towards the body and I was all
wrapped up in fitness committee and now
that my mind is clear and I know I
should not be tormenting my body in that
way
I don't think this is the career for me
so great great news said the youngest
[ __ ] I know this is a this is amazing
hmm do you understand how big of a win
this is for you do you know many people
work for 30 years in something they hate
and then like retire and then just like
mope through life this is a future this
is like the best mm-hmm I know and it's
frustrating because it should be time
and now you're gonna you're gonna love
other things yeah what are you gonna
just love that [ __ ] 22 they're gonna
love everything yeah so I was just gonna
ask you um do you have any insight as to
what my next steps could look like yeah
you need to you need to literally
explore every random thought in your
mind around cooking and skiing and and
making bread and being a wine expert and
being a video game expert and hair
and like your next step needs to be
exploring just like everyone's next step
should be right like literally anything
that grabs your curiosity you need to
watch youtube videos you need to try you
need to order a kit you need to find a
friend you need to talk to people
Twitter about it you need to join a
Facebook group about it you need to
follow ten people about it like you need
to go explore mm-hmm and that's what I
do that - I'm it's funny my parents make
that but I know you've said it like
ultra-strength but you say like you're
allowed to keep your mind and my problem
is like once I find something I'm like
in love with it and then I just kind of
like you're not in love with it you're
in crush with it and then you figure out
that you're not in love with it I lost
that when you but when you find what
you're in love with that crush will go
to love right you're not in love with it
you're in crush with it you have a crush
on it you baking I crush you yeah but
then three weeks later you like [ __ ]
this powder you know this I don't like
this flower [ __ ] you know what I mean
like I don't want to wait for the
pumpkin pie to come out next mm-hmm
who's skiing you're cute oh I don't like
tearing my meniscus like next like like
you're gonna crush with it right that's
good thank you okay I know smart like I
knew you were gonna like bring me down
and help me out so look let me let me
keep building here and give you a little
more mm-hmm
you're 20 - you don't need to figure out
what you're gonna do with your life ever
let alone in the next five years you
need to focus on being happy right and I
like what's funny that's actually a good
segue into my like second part of my
question um so it's crazy like eating
disorders in like I'm sure Frank Doyle
probably knows what I'm talking about
when I say this like it's just like this
cloud comes over your brain and like you
block her out the world like I had
tunnel vision I all I did in high school
was
go to school then I'd have like football
practice I'd come home I'd work now and
then I do homework and go to bed and I
only let myself eat a certain amount of
calories and so obviously that's gonna
have an effect on your brain and I miss
her on so much of my life like my
cheating gears and I can't get them back
me too guess we all missed out on him
and let's focus on your next 100 years
and not dwell on your last six exactly
so with that when I was stuck in eating
disorder um obviously like I said I
didn't like I didn't really know
differently like I thought that's what I
wanted and everything so now that I'm
recovering and I see that there's so
much more quiet of this I don't want
anyone else to go through what I did so
keep doing what you're doing right now
so how do I actually change their
perspective when making them cracked on
them by telling my story by telling your
story let me ask you a question said
okay if I told you when you were 99 and
we were and you came to heaven I was
like you know Sid remembers he was
carrying me
you're like hey Gary Ben I'm like good I
would say hey remember when we talked in
2020 and you asked that question I said
just make and you made a bunch of
instagrams and tic TOCs and youtubes but
then after six months you stopped
because it wasn't getting traction and
you went on and thank god you're so
great you listened to me and you became
the greatest skiing instructor of all
time well I don't know if you know this
but this is what's cool about heaven let
me show you the woman who you impacted
she was one girl in you know in Peru in
Winnipeg in the south side of Chicago
who did watch you know you're 87 views
on this on this one YouTube video in
2020 187 people watched it but here's
Karen the one person who watched it who
you actually had she not seen that video
he was what happens about this is what
what her life would have been dad at 31
because she'd destroyed her body but
because of your video that only got 87
views here was her life grandma happy
life
wouldn't it be worth it yeah and so
stick with me okay so then make the
video you don't need to be eight million
on Instagram you don't need to be
[ __ ] dr. Phil or Oprah mm-hmm just
make the [ __ ] video one person one
person one person I had I've been in
that mindset the whole time said now
it's more than one person but I'm still
in the one person game right and I love
that I love like how I know you all
right you train a couple minutes but I
love how humble you are about it and you
know I've been doing that I do have a
tik-tok I've been posting like minimum
four times a day and I'm not doing it
for the followers that could care less
about that I just want I don't know how
to actually get it to the people who I'm
trying to I find you not ditching
villified you put hash tag you know put
six hash tags in your tick-tock and
Instagram and I'll find you if you don't
think there's little girls left and
right putting hash tag getting to sort
clicking hash tag eating disorder hash
tag bulimia like if you don't think
that's happening you're out of your mind
put the hash tags in there making the
content they'll find you okay somebody's
gonna find your tik-tok in 19 years
and it's gonna help her tell the truth
one person tell the truth one person
they'll find you people are worried
about getting bigger focus on putting
out the message that's what I want like
I want to even obviously start with one
person but like I'm a dreamer and it
might bring like I'd love to like speak
in front of her I understand and help
them or they understand but that means
you're worried about you mm-hmm yeah
what about them
yeah and I want that to you like I have
said so many people roll up in me and
like Karen I want to be like you I want
to give today and then you listen to the
next 13 things out of their mouth and
they're saying I'm one of a hundred
thousand are speaking and drive in
private jets and have fun like they're
not about that giving life
if you want to help them and help them
make the videos is helping them they'll
find you of course you want to speak in
all this I get that and maybe you're
good enough and maybe or not that's okay
but one more time with the heav'n story
wouldn't it be worth it and just like
you figured out something else wasn't in
the cards for you you may find out that
you speaking on public stages about this
is not in the cards for you either and
that will be amazing or maybe it will be
but you're never gonna figure it out if
you're not completely in a selfless mind
state of producing content on all the
platforms people don't produce on all
the platforms cause like I have no
Twitter followers so they don't wanna
have three Twitter followers because
they're not worried about the audience
to worry about themselves they don't
want to waste their time right they
don't like it how it feels to have no
audience mm-hmm so then if like I know I
want it like I want to make those videos
make an impact even on that one person
but what do I do if that one person
doesn't want to hear it like I think
like they just don't believe you didn't
believe anybody either back then yeah I
know sweetheart
most of the people don't believe the
[ __ ] that's coming out of my mouth they
say they believe it but they don't act
on it which means they don't believe it
mm-hmm the the student always finds the
teacher right there's that saying right
the student finds some some sure like
that right yeah listen to me they will
find it they're people we've been
watching this in the comments I don't
know what you're watching on but I'm
gonna watch it there are people who've
listened to me for four years and then
it was one time
one video they were ready I broke them
down they broke themselves down mm-hmm
you know you know if they don't want to
hear it there's nothing me and you were
gonna do about it
yeah more importantly go back to what I
said the one person if everybody here
who wants the [ __ ] fame and the
action focused on just one person in
their life which would be so worth it
by human standards it's [ __ ] huge
it's [ __ ] up what's the matter with
people impacting one person and making
their life better is all time why do you
think like it's all time yeah somebody
really ready to hear you okay but if you
start putting out for the purpose of
helping one person versus
how do I get more followers your content
will be different
yeah content is different you'll start
working yeah
and this I'm so sorry and I have people
it's like I've been coming on to talk
like just like speaking to the camera
talking without like good serious news
but I'd seen some other people doing
like what they eat in a day and I
persona like the best like do you want
to do that not really here so don't
don't [ __ ] do it just because they
have 8,000 followers or 8 million
followers because they do that that's
works for them you do you yeah take a
nice little song in the background so
they find you through a trending song
use the hashtags and [ __ ] stay
consistent okay one person you don't
need to figure out your life in the next
10 years I don't give a [ __ ] what your
parents say okay so much game welcome
back Frank
whoo good show even late for my next
meeting Justin this is one of the best
shows dust
they were like baggers this was like a
great album yeah and here they're good a
lot of good quotes too yeah there's a
ton of [ __ ] I'm gonna be so pissed at
the team if we don't have at least six
[ __ ] instagrams out of this there's
some leak bangers here yeah this was as
good of a shout like it was consistently
like high-quality like good vibes I was
in a good zone like this is one of the
better shows it's the able Frank oh yeah
yeah I mean Abel Franco part definitely
started me off right you know and
running up those [ __ ] hills this
morning I really think that it was a
good one like I feel like this was one
of the better shows sign up for wine
text check out all-in challenge
comm-pass on the show to others please
if you do anything take the URL you just
hit watch this on and share in your
social I love you guys see how well I
like that nice plain text thanks mom
love you see you guys the people that
are gonna
over the next five to seven years are
gonna be very comfortable and controlled
[ __ ] chaos you don't love the process
requires sacrifice all your actions have
to then map to backpack backpack
backpack nobody gives a [ __ ] about where
you feel the whole game and scaling the
unscalable it's [ __ ] hard work it's
being respectful it's being a good
person who that that's just a good idea
it's there the flip thing is there this
house right here there's $400 to do it I
stay my lady
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled
everybody here judging themselves you're
looking at what's in front of you right
now
you're losing cuz you're laying in your
bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're upside let me
just say one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground who the [ __ ]
you are whoever provides the most value
always you're entering the greatest five
year window of your life my only answer
today or any much like it's just like
try [ __ ] don't your business down and go
work for an apparel company beginners
nobody you've ever met got that without
the hard work so you better get your
speed up you better work harder you
better work smarter you can't Google
stuff you're not gonna be able to do
anything that I'm telling Gary
be my vehicle to check me out hope you
enjoy